Hi, hi.
Hello.
Hi again.
If I just saw you, hello.
Hello again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Karaoke time.
I don't know if it'll be very long.
My brain is jello, mushiness from stressing everything.
X no say happy birthday!
Here, we'll do a ha- Wait, is our first song going to be a
happy birthday song?
Maybe we just get it out of the way, huh?
Happy birthday.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
This is a bit of a warm-up.
A little warm-up for...
For it, for everything.
Hold on, I need to drink more water.
Oh, I'm out of water.
Okay, I have my water bottle.
But inside is juice.
It's not water.
That's fine.
Yummy.
Okay.
Of course, Appy Juice.
I always don't know what happy birthday song I choose before
Let's do Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to
you Happy birthday to you
Great warm-up team, great warm-up, happy birthday everybody.
Happy birthday, everyone.
I also forgot to set up set list.
There we go.
Thank you!
Here you have myself, Kim Vindo, and the new song is so
beautiful.
Thank you for these summer gifts.
Can't wait for the concert on Friday.
Yes!
Oh, I forgot to mention, if you like the song.
You might be excited for Friday!
If you like the song, maybe.
Friday might be really exciting.
Oh, set list.
Wait.
Oh, big.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if I love the song?
Then you might be even more excited for Friday if you are
watching Den's Let's do it.
Legend of New First 3D live.
Really appreciate my favorite VTuber outfit ever.
That's a huge honor.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm really glad that you guys seem to like it so much.
So, I was worried.
You know, I was like, it's quite a simple outfit.
And simple is not bad.
But I was like, maybe people are going to be expecting some
crazy things.
You know, VTuber outfits can go as crazy as they want to go,
but I always think about artists and cosplayers and such and
if...
Daddy!
Yay!
Simple and clean.
Right.
Maybe we can sing that tonight.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe we can sing that tonight.
Oh.
New album and song are so cute.
Are you sad?
yeah oh gosh my my my kokoro is still so so i feel i feel
like jello so i feel truly i mean i am jello i'm basically
ectoplasm but i uh i um hopefully hopefully i can sing okay
i wrote down some songs that i wanted to sing um but mainly
it's anything goes so mainly it's anything goes simple is
appreciated by us artists yes yes mint could you try i could
try i could try really matches no it really matches tori no
utah i think that's a good one to start with too i think
think.
That is a super summer song.
These, I saw a tweet today being like, anytime it's summer,
this is the song I want to listen to.
Mayushi!
New outfit, lovely background makes you think life is
beautiful.
Tori no utah.
Karoku.
Hold on, I see you guys in super chats.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Win-to-Sekai-Ichibun!
Kawaii!
Great outfit, love to have a great early song.
Big concert soon.
So proud to have you as an OG.
Thank you very much.
We like anything even a red pinned on dress on you.
Dope.
I might have to go get some actual water soon though.
Perhaps.
Aquarium!
Wait, that's a good song too.
I'll add it to the list.
Okay, let's sing a tori no utah.
I was... Oh my gosh, it's funny that you brought up full
moon because I was...
Oh, hold on, it's a little quiet.
I was thinking...
Yesterday or today, I was like, oh, I really want to sing
full moon songs, but full moon is such a winter show, no?
Who cares?
Maybe I'll sing anyway.
Full moon...
Anyway, okay.
I sing.
This thing was not even too long ago actually.
It's the summer anime song I think.
you
I'm so nervous and I'm so nervous.
I know the bird will not be able to fly, but I'll be able to
hear it.
I don't know where it will be.
Oh,
it's the best of the wrong.
I forgot to mention too!
Actually, I had to!
I had to!
So maybe yesterday in Japan, but today, Today in America,
it's Luminaries.
That's the way the moon is the same as the other end.
The moon and the other end of that world is always the same
dream and I always look like a dream.
I'm looking at the same place that I'm always looking at.
The dream is a dream.
A blue-darker, yaked-dark, Ake-dark, set of the old
The old shape of the world A-darker, the seasons The last
day of the world A-darker-gig-go A-darker-cate-boying
A-z A-darker Two-darker-darking-darking I'm always going to
be straight My naga-zashi will have you My naga naga naga My
naga naga My naga
My naga
My naga My naga
Yay!
That was Tori No Uta!
Also, Steiner, don't make me ban you.
Stop using the Den Setu channel for evil.
Tori No Uta, Tori No Uta!
Yeah.
No, yeah.
I'll try to go through all the different versions so that...
Check it out that everybody who hasn't seen, I can see...
Ooh!
Well, thank you!
Mobius, thank you!
Your new overlord is absolutely gorgeous and cute,
resembling the color of purity!
Well, I mean I'm a ghost, so...
Your new song reflects all your sparkling beauty, wow!
Such high praise.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, oh, what should I sing?
what should i sing I have a song I want to sing I have a
song I was listening to the song earlier I don't know for
some reason this feels like a summary song to me again today
is anything goes I'm trying to do summer songs but kind of
anything goes let's see okay Do I have to do this plus two?
I think so.
Maybe we want to say good night, team.
What is this?
Gravity's holding me back.
I want
nothing to say.
When everything gets in the way.
Seems you cannot be replaced.
And I'm the one who will stay.
In this world, it's just us You know it's not the same as it
was In this world, it's just us You know it's not the same
as it was As it was, as it was I'm not the same Answer the
phone We know you're no good alone Why are you sitting at
home on the floor?
What kind of pills are you on?
Ringing the bell That nobody's coming to hell Your daddy
lives by himself Just wants to know that you're well Oh, in
this world It's just us You know it's not the same as it was
In this world, it's just us You know it's not the same as it
was As it was, as it was You know it's not the same Go home,
get ahead, life's beat, internet I don't want to talk about
the way that it was Leave America, two kids, follow her I
don't want to talk about who's doing it first Hey!
Oh, that was early!
As it was!
You know, it's not the same as it was As it was As it was
it's okay it's okay i told you my brain is jelly as it was
as it was you know it's not the same thank you so much for
all those super chats and gifted memberships you guys thank
you so so so so so so so much thank you
i'm gonna
stick here and there is a very summer car karaoke vibe so
true so true vicky free summer from fairly odd parents i
don't even know that song there's a summer song in fairly
odd parents
there's summer songs in fairly odd parents who knew who knew
Can you do shiny teeth on me?
My shiny teeth that twinkles just like the stars in space My
shiny teeth that sparkle in your face My shiny teeth that...
They are not veneers Shiny teeth and shiny teeth and shiny
teeth at me I can't wait to see everyone perform on Friday
besides that guess who managed to get a ticket to your meet
and greet on saturday at the open sales philip let's go
let's go i'll see you there i'll see you there
wait that's a good one so not the summer song but actually
all the footage all the footage that i took uh from the
music video was at enoshima and so i edited it together
in in in in uh in in oh in bunny girl senpai they go to
anoshima so it actually kind of works but before that i do
want to sing another song the the um the uh oh my gosh my
brain i'm so sorry the uh the composer of my song kasaki
cider he did kutsuke kibonu and so i would like to I would
like to sing that.
Yeah.
I would like to sing that song.
Wait, I have to find...
Hold on.
Wait.
Chow chow my tea.
Chow my tea.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Do.
Yes.
Is this it?
Oh, let me get the music.
Let me test the music real quick.
I don't trust my song with any song.
Brain too mush.
I'm not gonna be lonely I'm a bit more and I'm a bit more
colorful and more colorful memories
It's just an instant No, it's just gonna be No, no, no No,
no, no No,
no, no No, no No, no
Thank you
bonnew by my favorite idol girl group Dempagumi Inc.
And again, my original song was composed by the same
composer.
And actually, I asked, I was like, I'm really nervous.
I really wanted to rap in it because he is very famous for
his rapping skills.
Like the guy has been making music since the 90s.
His Kaseki Saider San is so amazing.
I love his music so much.
His work is amazing.
how is my rap i'm really i'm really i'm really nervous about
it and he said that my rap was great and i have a talent for
it maybe and that it really clicked with my voice and that
he would love to work with me again hopefully so yeah i was
like the highest praise i've ever heard ever
got to I we actually had a meeting with him back in March
and him and his manager and that long long trip that we were
filming um burn on for and everything too and I go so I got
to meet him in person I was like whoa I was like I'm a big
fan he's like I don't know anything about vtubers I was like
that's okay I just want I just want your music I just want
It was really high praise, right?
I was so honored.
He seemed really interested, though.
He has been so nice to work with.
He's a really nice guy.
So I was very excited.
The translator I went with, it was pretty funny because the
translator I went with, he actually helped with the music
video as well.
Paki.
Paki, I went with him.
And he's like old school Gundam Otaku.
and so is Kasaki Sider and so they were like bonding over
they were bonding over over old like Mecha anime and Gundam
and stuff and it was really really awesome so it was really
nice it was really nice oh I did want to say I did have a
logo made for the song unfortunately it could not get done
in time but I didn't want to put it off anymore but you
might see like the the thumbnail update some point with the
with the new logo
yes yes yes otaku to otaku communication yeah he was really
like excited he like kaseki uh kaseki cider sam was really
excited he was like i know really get to talk to people
about stuff like this so i was sitting there like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was just i was just hyping him up it was
great it was fun it was so fun i was very nervous though oh
let's see um oh wait there was aquarium let me do that one
what is what is the full title aqua's aquarium
it's been so long since i've sung this song
we'll put on we'll put on my we'll put on both for this
What was I gonna say?
I don't remember.
Whatever.
Let's go.
Party Can you see my car?
Very, very, very Very, very Fucca, pucca, Fucca, Fucca,
Fucca, Can you hear me?
Can you come closer?
Yeah!
Fucca Fucca Fucca,
that's the way of I'm a big fan Yeah!
I'm kidding I'm not gonna lie I'm keeping it down Yeah!
Yeah!
So I'm gonna be honest I don't wanna I don't wanna hide my
heart
I love the water So I'm in the water No, no, no, no I'm not
allowed to spoil I'm not allowed to do something you know,
today's season one, but I know, oh my gosh, my reading
comprehension is so bad I do, I do, I do, I do, I do, I do,
I do, I do, I do, I love you, I love you
Chimony Kito Kito Kino
Fantastic Eyes Muna Yay It's the first No need, no need No
need
No I love I love
No Oh, oh, oh Come on, let's go Let's go Chomp, chomp
Fantasy I'm the Tockimeki No Oh
yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, that was something
I eventually got my footing there Eventually, eventually
Yay!
What if I sing a song that's not super summary?
Wait, hold on, let's sing a Fudermoon of Suggeste.
Fudermoon of Suggeste.
Can't do Eternal Snow, though.
Anything goes, anything goes, anything goes.
Wait, I'm trying to remember.
It's been so long since I've...
song any of these maybe love Chronicle I remember the best
hold on I'm gonna listen to it for two seconds let's hear
thank you whoa thank you for the very big oh thank you oh
your new outfit looks so cute I can't wait to go home so I
can listen to a new cover you've inspired me to be more open
about my nerdiness and I'm so thankful about it.
Thank you so much.
Island song ED of Adventure Time.
I'm so sorry I don't know it.
I'm so sorry.
School Live Gakogurashi.
That's actually composed by that's a mosaic wave and they
did burn on.
And that's so great.
Oh my gosh.
All my favorite artists I'm able to work with.
I'm gonna cry.
I can't believe I get to work with all my people.
It is so awesome.
I get to say that.
Sorry.
I'm so happy.
Okay, okay.
I think I remember the song.
Wait, does it have Fudigana?
It does.
Okay, good.
I might be able to read it.
All right.
thing this is a love chronicle from um i might
not remember all of it though i might not remember all of it
though
I never knew.
I'd be the one.
The dirty sneaker on the day on the day of the day.
The honeycomb and your smile on the other day, on the day of
the day, it was like,
I love you so much love you, love me, I don't know why I'm
saying it right now, it's so good.
I love you, I give you the courage to give me.
For every time of my journey, I'm going to make you all
right now.
Whatever happens, I won't let you take away from me.
It's a little bit strange, isn't it?
It's always a special way to see it.
The flowers, the trees, the sea, the wind, the sun All, the
sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun
It's a long, chig, chig, chig, chig, chig, chig, chig so
It's the last piece I've been to the world A big and your
back I'm gonna keep it, keep it going, I'm gonna keep it
from forever I get that right?
I don't remember.
Bad.
It's the music video, I'm looking at the background of this,
it's people skiing, it's so distracting.
I was wrong there.
Wait, there's a here, sir.
What can happen to me?
I don't want to look my eyes on you, I want to love you, I
want to love you.
I want to go straight.
Wait, there's a here, sir.
I want to give it to you.
For the next time, for the two of you, I want to go.
Why are they skiing?
They even talk about the ocean in this.
Yay!
That was Love Chronicle.
Chronicle.
yo yo yo i saw a lot of oh no no no a lot of people asking
for this song hopefully i can sing it today hopefully i can
sing it today we'll see if my voice is okay
i've been like not coughing but kind of like
okay i think the song all the time too though I feel like
when you walk away you don't hear me say please oh baby
don't go simple and clean is the way that you're making me
feel tonight it's hard to let it go
giving me too many things lately you're all i need oh you
smiled at me and said don't get me wrong i love you but does
that mean i have to meet your father when we are older
you'll understand what i meant when i said no i don't think
life is quite that simple when you walk away you don't hear
me say please oh baby don't go simple and clean is the way
that you're making me feel tonight It's hard to let it go
There's no stopping points in the song so I can't swallow my
spit The daily things like this and that and what is what
That keep us all busy are confusing me That's when you came
to me And say, wish I could prove I love you, but does that
mean I have to walk on water?
When we are older, you'll understand it's enough when I say
so, and maybe some things are that simple.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, please.
Oh baby, don't go simple and clean is the way that...
Sorry, I'm choking on my spit.
It's hard to let it go.
Hold me.
Whatever lies me on this morning is a little later on,
regardless of warnings.
scare me at all nothing's like before when you walk away you
don't hear me say please obey me don't go simple and clean
is the way that you're making me feel tonight it's hard to
let it go me whatever lies beyond this morning is a little
later on regardless of mornings the future doesn't scare me
at all nothing's like before hold me whatever lies beyond
this morning is a little Regardless of warnings, the future
doesn't scare me at all.
Nothing's like before.
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm so, my mouth is full of, maybe it's the juice.
Maybe it's the apple juice.
Oh, man.
Oopsie.
You're awesome!
Pretty, thank you!
Oh.
Mmm.
Oh,
thank you for the extremely cute input to any summer model
we tell.
Please watch us all out to see with your summer vibes.
Okay!
Yeah, let's sing more songs.
Let's sing more summer songs.
Um...
Hmm.
I kind of want to sing this one.
Sorry.
I'm like, my dad vibes are coming out now.
Let's do...
Let's do this one.
Oh,
I forgot to add it.
We're tattered and torn.
We fuss and we fight and delight in the tears that we cry
until dawn.
Hold me now,
stay with me.
Let love in star, let love in star You say I'm a dreamer,
we're two of a kind.
Both of us searching for some perfect world we know we'll
never find.
Perhaps I should leave here Yeah, go far away But you know
that there's nowhere that I'd rather be Than with you here
today Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Hold me now Love
Stay with me Let loving start Oh, hold me now.
Yeah!
Warm my heart.
Stay with me.
Let love and start.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You ask if I love you.
I say You know that I do and that this is just one of those
games that we play So I sing you a new song Please don't cry
anymore I'll ask your forgiveness even though I don't know
just what I'm asking it for Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Oh, hold
me now.
Oh, oh, warm my heart.
Stay with me.
Let love it start.
Oh, hold me now.
Oh, warm my heart.
Oh, my cold and dying heart.
Stay with me.
Let love in star, let love in star, oh Hold me now Oh, warm
my heart Stay with me Let love in star, let love in star Oh,
hold me now Oh, warm my heart Stay with me.
Why does the background singer sound like a chipmunk?
Stay with me.
Love it, starlight, love it.
We had a cameo.
My gosh.
Alvin from Alvin and the chipmunks.
Thank you.
Hold me now.
Whoa.
This background singer is a super hot.
high in the OG too.
It's okay.
Because I did have to...
I feel like it was still so low.
Wait, let me see if I do times...
Or a plus 4 on this.
Because I feel like it was still a little...
A little low for me, right?
Let me hold on.
I have a picture.
Yeah, this feels better, right?
But then...
Hold on, let's hear the chipmunk.
Oh, well.
Hold me now.
Hold my heart.
Stay with me.
You live behind your...
Help me in your tired arms.
Yeah, let's do, let's do.
Sorry, I'm going through all the different hairstyles and
styles in case anybody hasn't seen it.
Hmm, let's see, um, what else did I have written down?
Oh, oh, I do kind of want to sing this one.
I feel like it's summary sounding.
Hmm, probably.
Yeah, he's putting his whole soul into the back of singing.
Um, um, the passionate squirrel photo.
Do you want to see it?
Do you want to see the passionate squirrel photo?
Squirrels are kissing.
Oh man, I gotta find it.
It's somewhere saved in here.
When they greet each other.
When they greet each other, they kiss.
They kiss.
Like that.
It always aches me laughed.
That was so passionate.
It's, oh, sorry, that was my phone.
It's such a passionate kiss.
It's so, it's a Renaissance photo, honestly.
You have the guy on the lookout.
Like, it seems like a, like a, like a hidden lover, like
situation, you know, where the guy is on the lookout and
they're both like meeting in secret.
They're passionately kissing because their time together is
so short.
Rongo, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Wait, I've missed so many gifted.
Me, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's a Renaissance painting to me.
Oh, what did I just delete?
Oh, wait, why did the voice just sound?
Where'd my phone go?
Oh, man.
It's yelling at me.
Hold on.
Are you okay?
are you good yeah it's okay it's okay i think yeah it's okay
secret rendezvous in the third wheel no no he's he's he's
team score his team their their relationship he is he is
he's he's happy he's look happy to be on the lookout to see
if anybody is watching
i I want to sing this song next.
Actually, I'll save this one for a bit later.
Let's sing this next song that I was going to sing.
Okay.
Let me see.
I think this one's...
I didn't write any notes.
He's a wing squail.
Colin, thank you so much for the five gifted things.
Thank you.
Does squirrels make each other's plenty of nuts to reap?
What does that mean?
When you said the big minto plushie with spread eagle
reminds me when a viewer's friend's mom thought that you...
What is that your goose arms were?
Don't remind me!
Luckily, they're not up.
Luckily, I can put them down sometimes.
Oh my gosh, break it down.
I don't know when it will come through because it might be
backlogged from all of the gifted.
But thank you so much for the big...
For the Akadono!
So happy, Mayoshi gets to be so cute.
That makes so many amazing songs and performances with pros.
Congrats, Vito.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
The Watcher, happy to look out for his friends, yet still
yet, yearns for the love he knows he cannot have.
Stop!
I don't like this!
I don't, I don't like this!
I don't I don't want to I know this tragic it's too tragic
Shadow Cross thank you for that Thank you for that No no no
no no No no no I sing the next song
I could stare like watching stars Bye, and I'll tell without
a thought You'd be mine, would you mind If I took your hand
to mine You'll like all that I want Make this life I'll
imagine we fell in love I'll nap under moonlight skies with
you I think I'll picture us The ocean's colors on your face
I'll leave my heart with your air So let me fly with you
Will you be forever with me?
I'll always stay by you I'll keep it safe So don't you worry
a thing I'll tell you I love you you more it's stuck with
you forever so promise you won't let it go i'll trust the
universe will always bring me to you
i'll imagine we fell in love i'll nap under moonlight skies
with you i think i'll picture us you with the waves the
ocean's colors on your face I'll leave your heart with your
air So let me fly with you Will you be forever with
me?
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue Yay, I have another,
wait, can I go potty real quick?
I'll play, I'll play my original song while I go potty,
listen to it.
to make sure it doesn't blast your ears oh i can't oh wait
there we go yes okay good okay all right here we go i'll be
right back
That's the cure, cure the cure
Where we
go, we're at the mercy of it Cure, the cure is the cure That
heavy summer It's always been the cure Cure's, cure, the
cure Cure's the cure It's the cure, the cure k appenditt to
that coalition kittitt kittitt kitt
kitt kitt but kittittitt that loves you kittittittittees yay
yay yay Oh, welcome back.
Thank you.
Oh, the new song, new alfamito.
Thank you for everything you do.
All the hard work you've been putting in recently is
amazing.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I heard the minky, minky, minky.
Thank you, Rickadon.
Thank you so much.
I didn't grab water, but that's okay.
That's okay.
I still have my juice.
I hope everybody will be like, I kind of wanted like an
earworm where you just kind of go around and you go Kyun
des, Kyun des, Kyun des, Kyun des ura meshiya desu, Kyun
desu, Kyun desu.
JPから, oh hayo!
Hayao kodaiimasu!
Oh, one verse is the world!
Thank you so much for the 10 captain!
Miss Noom, thank you!
Your karaoke blue was my comfort song I had downloaded.
No way!
up you'll make me tear up don't tear up you'll make me tear
up oh love the new outfit it's so cute and the new song is
amazing thank you jackson thank you applying the kune death
parasite to the lettuce right now i remember when i got the
lyrics i was like oh my gosh this is this is great this is
so awesome let's see hmm um today's karaoke will not be so
long just because you know um uh it was a lot preparing you
you probably can't tell you know but there was a lot of
stress over preparing for the outfit and a lot of work you
can't tell probably that's that's fine hello miito and i was
like yeah the outfit is long amazing and i'm so so so proud
of you thank you
i was i was stressing over my computer was like exploding
every time i was rendering the video for some reason it just
hated it hated all the effects and everything and i was like
i'm doing my best please i'm doing my best i'm doing my best
but that's okay We can tell you're very relieved.
I was also, I was just so many, it was so, so many nerves to
be like, well, people like it.
So, cute and death, cute and death.
Oh, let's do two more songs.
Hmm.
Oh.
Can't say goodbye to yesterday.
That's a good one.
Espresso, okay, we'll do a couple.
Orca, I've seen you.
I've heard you.
We'll do espresso.
I'll do espresso for you.
I've seen you.
I've seen you over the past couple of karaoke's even.
Actually, there's a couple more songs I want to do.
Maybe, hold on, I'm going to write a list.
Okay, maybe, let's get to like 14.
Because, let's get to 14.
Wait, okay, espresso.
Okay, wait, that's three.
New outfit, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, that's, that should be good for now.
Oh, oh
Now he's thinking about me every night Oh, isn't that sweet,
I guess so Say you can't sleep, baby, I know That's that me
espresso Move it up, down, left, right Oh, switch it up like
Nintendo Say you can't sleep, baby, I know That's that me
espresso relate to desperation my give-up freaks are on
vacation and i got this one girl and you won't stop calling
when they act this way i know i gotta have to buy your ex
don't do it for ya walked in and drinking shoot it for ya
soft skin and i perfumed it for ya yes i know i'm out and do
it for ya that morning call I'll be brooded for ya One touch
and I brand new did for ya Now he's Think about me every
night oh Isn't that sweet I guess so Say you can't sleep
baby I know That's not me espresso Move it up down, left
right oh Switch it up like Nintendo Say you can't sleep baby
I know That's not me espresso Isn't that sweet I guess so
And lay Cause I'm a streamer Oh he looks so cute Wrapped
around my finger My twisted humor Make him laugh so often My
honeybee Come and get this falling Too proud your ex don't
do it for ya Walk in and dream came true They for ya But
stop getting I perfumed it for ya Yes I know I'm mountain do
it for ya That morning cough Be brooded for you One touch
and eyebrow Muted for you Now he's Think about me every
night Oh, isn't that sweet?
I guess so Say you can't sleep, baby I know Has that me
espresso Move it up, down, left, right Oh, switch it up like
Nintendo Say you can't sleep, baby I know Has that me
espresso Think about me every night Oh, isn't that sweet?
I guess so Yes, say you can't sleep Baby, I know That's that
me espresso Move it up down, left right Oh, switch it up
like Nintendo Say you can't sleep, baby, I know That's that
me espresso It's that sweet, I guess so That's that me
espresso Actually, oh, I forgot the reverb Actually, this
was my idea I asked for this I asked I asked for for the
silhouette and what's the funny thing is too you'll never
see it probably ever because I stream from here so you just
have to know it's secretly there but what's a sundress if
not the Right?
At least a little bit.
Yeah.
Can you sing Hilary Duff?
So yesterday, so yesterday.
I regret to inform you that's the only part I know.
But I know another part.
I know another song.
I know another Hilary Duff song.
I can sing.
I know this one.
Then we can sing with my glasses on Because it's a ball Hey
now, hey now Hey now, hey now Have you ever seen such a
beautiful night?
I could almost kiss the stars We're shining so bright When I
see you smile, I go, oh, oh, oh I would never want to miss
this Cause in my heart, I know what this is Hey now, hey
now, this is what dreams I'm made of Hey now, hey now, this
is what dreams I'm made of Somewhere I belong, somebody to
love This is what dreams I'm made of This is what dreams I'm
made of Have you ever wondered what life is about?
You could search the world and never figure it out Hell the
oceans No, no, no Happiness is no mystery It's here and now
It's you and me Yeah!
Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of Hey, hey,
hey, hey Hey, hey, hey Hey, now, hey This is what dreams are
made of Got somewhere I've been lost Somebody to love This
is what dreams Are made of Hey now
This is what dreams are made of Shout to the skies This is
what dreams are made of Then I see your smile And I go
Yesterday my life was duller Now everything's typical
Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of This is
what dreams are made of I've got somewhere I belong
I feel so
cool in my glasses.
Do you guys like them?
You guys like my glasses?
How do you like my sunglasses?
Love them?
What dreams are made of?
Wait, oh, I'm all wrong.
Hey now, hey now.
Great look for you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you think so.
Can you do any Anri songs?
Oh, wow.
It's funny that you mentioned.
and I, because I had one on the list.
I gotta learn some more songs, though.
I've been too busy with other things.
I did a couple new ones today, though.
Luckily.
Uh, hold on.
Hmm.
I think I have a song I want to sing.
Someone inspired me.
Wait, hold on.
Without...
Okay, okay, okay.
We're good.
Minky Maguire.
Thank you so much for the adorable outfit.
You look so cute.
Oh, I always really loved your new cover.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dreadnought.
Let's see.
Song number 11.
I want to sing this one.
I feel like I haven't sung this.
went in a long time i'll try it wait
yes okay try to find one with no guide wait does this have
the guide guide adi guide nashi guide don't nashi
have it.
Okay.
I'll try.
Jammer, moan, yana, moan, nanta, kesther This world, moor,
what do you do?
Say music You're the magic When you close your eyes, you
open your eyes, you open your eyes to the end, you're always
going to end, you're going to hear this song I'll sing, oh
Do you want to play the real game?
Giri, giri, tina wata, like a semi-tata I wanna be free I
wanna be free I can't be free
I can't be more than you can see me I can't believe you can
see me
believe me
I'm a boy Real and colorful, give me your music Now I'm
starting, rising My eyes are closed and everyone will hear
me I'm gonna show you I want to know this song, I want to
know.
Do you want to play the real game?
Giri-giri, tina-wattari, like a dream.
I don't want to be able to get back, I want to let it be.
I want to be free.
I can see the new world, the world to the world.
Now I can go, the new world.
The new world, the new world,
Yeah, that was One Piece Shinji Dai Shinji Dai Shinji Dai
Yeah Of course I cannot I even come a fraction close to how
Ado sings it But Ado is in a completely amazing league Did I
get rated?
Hi!
Thank you!
Hello, hello Hello Hello The next song is actually A winter
song And then we'll go back to two summer songs.
Hold on, I keep...
Reveal is one of the best.
Thank you!
Everlasting love plus you from Katamari Forever.
I don't think I know it.
You look so cute.
Thank you, Barrybug.
Thank you, Barry.
Oh, wait, Barry rated.
Thank you!
Did you guys see that a Barrybug has a cover coming out
tomorrow?
Tomorrow.
That, oh, you should check it out on Barry's channel.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, wait, yeah, I was going to sing Fukashigi no Karute.
Wait, I can sing that.
Wait, I got it, I got it, I got it.
I have to find my karaoke.
I was thinking, I was thinking, I think I was trying to find
my karaoke for it earlier and I forgot.
Actually, I have a couple more songs I want to sing.
I'm such a liar.
I have a couple more songs I want to sing.
Is that okay?
I wonder who's in it.
I wonder.
I wonder, I wonder.
See, where did the song go?
Karaoke.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Here we go.
Wait, hmm.
Do I have the karaoke for it still?
Wait.
A, A, A, are you?
Oh, wait, maybe I don't.
No!
Wait.
I don't think I have it anymore.
Wait a minute.
I think I have to go find it on...
I find a karaoke of it on YouTube.
Life is so tough.
After life is so tough even.
this might have a guide i don't know
never reality and both both true and truth don't don't
I love Don't
worry about it.
I want to be loved.
Mugya, mugya, Sayonara, A light mugya, A lot of you are not
in the real world.
Who can't be loved?
Hardly,
Did you guys see my new song, my new original, the footage
is taken in?
The world's world is always coming along I want to be back
to
you The
saddest dream is The saddest voice is A beautiful,
beautiful, Udaya-gaw-shin, Udaya-yay-mashin, Aday, Who's it?
Who?
I can't tell, I can't, I can't, I can't see my eyes Like a
showtime No one can't call me I can't see I just want to
know only.
Yay!
Fukashi-gy-no-carter!
Fukashi-gy-no-carter.
Yay!
Thank you for the collapse!
Thank you, thank you.
And since we are on this lovely...
lovely sunset beach as where other lovely sunset beach
things happen.
Thanks for an incredible Monday, Minky-sama!
I'll do a few more songs.
I'm trying to decide what I want to...
Okay.
Three more songs.
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you for guys for the summer songs!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
This next one...
Oh, I need the melee patch four.
This next song I need an eye patch for.
Actually, which one do I want to do?
Let's do this song.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Petals are wide, cover fields flowing in grieving tears.
And all the hearts, once new, old and shattered now Love can
kill, love will die, give me wings to fly Bleeding this
world so cold, I just wonder why
Cold as the dark, now my words are frosted with every breath
Still the hate burns wild growing inside this heart When the
wind changes course, when the stars align I will reach out
to you and leave this all behind When heaven's divine
I will see the choices within my heart hands how can we ever
oh sorry to attack and fight with our tiny souls let me
shine like the Sun through the doubts and fear do you feel
the storm approach As the end draws me When heaven's new
life Time will come to softly lay me down Then I can see a
face That I long to see And for you Only you I would give
anything Leaving a trace for love To find a way When
heaven's divine I'll
dive into the fire Spilling the blood of my desire The very
last time My name is scorched into The sky When heaven's
divine I will see the choices within my How can we ever
protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heaven's still by, time will come to softly lay me
down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you I would give up.
Leaving a trace for love to find.
of anything leaving a trace for love to find a way when
heavens divide
oh gosh the air quality is so bad here today i'm so sorry
guys my voice keeps cracking
Yaya, yo, yo, yo.
Thank you for the song, boys.
I still get chills every time you sing it.
Oh, thank you.
Amfa Amir, thank you so much for the birthday, good evening.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.amoak boys, big boys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
That's my ghost and my name.
Navarro, thank you so much for the Thank you, thank you so
much.
Vic boss.
Vic boss, Vic boss.
Amazing.
Mission complete that there.
Why are the best boss?
The one and only.
My mission is not yet complete.
I still want to sing a couple more songs.
Here, let's uh...
Vic mint!
I'll try this one.
I feel like my voice is giving out, though, so...
Probably...
Actually, you know what?
Let's just make this the last one.
I was going to do...
I can't stop the...
Loneliness by Andive.
I will have to save it for another time because my voice is
starting to give out for real, so.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I can't stop down.
The loneliness.
Actually, there's a couple songs I didn't get to do today.
That's okay, though.
I'll say, okay, I have fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed it as well.
I hope you guys enjoyed the karaoke.
We'll do one last song.
Whatever could it be.
Whatever could this final song be that...
Did you know...
Thank you, thank you.
Phoenix, thank you!
Call me Tuny, but I put this on last Solar Eclipse.
mean?
What does that mean?
You guys know I put out a new song?
Isn't that crazy?
Wouldn't it be crazy to hear it?
Do you guys want to hear my new song, Uda Mishi Summer,
Lingering Summer?
Do you guys want to hear it?
Actually, I have a little tidbit about the song.
I have a little tidbit.
Give me one second.
Wait, I can't find the instrument.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
whoa that's kind of loud uh the tidbit is the song was
originally called lonesome city boy but we talked with cider
son and we were like i'm really looking more for like a
summery vibe more than like a city vibe especially because i
had already filmed the music video right and so um but so
originally instead of like kum des kum des it was Lonesome,
Lonesome, Lonesome, Lonesome, which you can hear at the very
end, like during the CUNES, CUNES, you can hear him saying
Lonesome, Lonesome, he added his vocals in.
So I'm kind of singing along with Sider Sun in the song.
It's so awesome here.
I'll play a little bit so you can hear.
Can you hear it?
So it adds like an extra bit of like layering and depth to
the song.
I really, really love it.
So yeah, now you know that little, you know, that little bit
of tidbit.
Okay, let's sing my last song.
This is my new original song, Ura Meshi Summer
Ura Meshiya Ura Meshiya Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun
Ura Meshiya
Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun
Kiyun Kiyun This
I'm a messier CUNY CUNY That love No No CUNY CUNY
The mew endless Love Love Love Love I want to know I want to
know I'm
a messier
That moment CUNY
CUNY CUNY Thank
you and for the karaoke.